La volta al món a peu, dia 75.
Nit tranquil·la.
Estic veient que la dinàmica és una nit bona, una nit dolenta, una nit que dorm molt bé i una que malament.
Avui ha sigut bé.
Ha plogut també aquesta nit, per variar, però avui no hi ha vessal.
Avui no hi ha vessal, per sort.
No sé si és que avui m'he dedicat a pensar millor els extrems de la tenda i tal.
Més d'hora de l'habitual, també, 7.30.
Això també està bé.
Val, què ens espera el dia d'avui?
Doncs seguim amb el temps, seguim amb...
Bé, ara no plou, però després ha de ploure, una mica de vent, una mica de fred.
Però avui, en teoria, passarem per un poble, un poble amb serveis, com Déu mana,
però serà d'aquí 15 quilòmetres.
Per tant, primera meitat del dia, 3 hores, carretera.
Bm, 2, 1...
Got-got-got...
Hup, hup...
This, goth...
Això de veure gossos sencalligar, que surten aquí a marcar una mica el territori,
m'havia passat a Georgia, on ell va veure la travessa transcaucàsica,
que tinc al meu canal de YouTube,
amb sorpreses bastant desagradables, però que és una meitat clickable.
agradables. Aquí a
Croàcia no ho he vist encara.
Tots els cossos estan lligats o amb una
tanca.
He tingut aquí un petit esglai al principi.
Però bé, bé, bé.
Bueno, només intentava
marcar-me per dir, ei,
no t'acostis. Comença a ploure.
Avui he sortit sense els pantalons
de pluja,
perquè realment caminar amb ells, bueno,
és una mica més incòmode,
però me'ls hauré de posar i també la
gorra i tal.
Sort que,
mireu aquí, tenim
una parada de bus. Llavors, bueno, és una mica
més còmode ficar-se
aquí sota per resguardar-se mentre fica els pantalons
i tal.
No, avui
pico a meitat
de camí del teòric.
Dic teòric perquè ja no
fio de res, però sí, sí, del poble.
Tu, escolta, ahir
em va fer mal. Vaig acabar el dia
amb dolor a aquesta zona
del peu. No sé quin nom té.
I, bueno, durant la nit vaig estar
estirant la pota. Clar, no podia sortir
fora a fer estiraments com Déu mana perquè estava
plovent. Llavors vaig estar estirant el peu
així i tal, i aquest matí ja m'aixeco
sense cap dolor.
Vaig...
Vaig patir una mica per dir, ostres,
que no m'hagi agafat alguna cosa perquè, clar, estic fotent
bastanta canya. Però no, no, bé, bé, bé.
Bé. Però s'ha d'anar amb compte
d'estirar bé, de no forçar la màquina
perquè no vinguin aquests problemes musculars.
Arribat ja al primer poble,
Txesarica, però aquí no són ja
els serveis, per dir-ho així, sinó
el següent poble que està a 4 quilòmetres.
L'objectiu serà trobar-ne un obert
perquè
tot això és molt d'estiu,
molt de platja i
estarà tot tancat. Però, home,
com a mínim un.
Molt maco, no?, el passeig marítim aquest.
Ara he vingut des d'allà
i estic aquí
sota cobert.
Ja he arribat al poble aquest,
ara estic simplement a les afores.
Pluja, eh? Plou amb
certa intensitat, bastant incòmoda.
Moment clau, eh?
A veure si trobo alguna cosa. No sé, potser
sembla que estic com massa
pensant en el tema que he de trobar un establiment,
un cafè, un restaurant... Però realment
amb aquests dies de pluja
el que et reconforta és estar
com...
calent i sec durant una hora
o el que sigui. Realment és
com un xute, un xute d'energia,
no sé com dir-ho.
Música
Voleu veure com és un cementiri
croat? Aquest és molt petit, eh?
No, no és tan petit.
Tots són
doncs tombes
en horitzontal, podríem dir, no?
No sé com dir-li aquesta cosa.
No són nínxols en vertical
com allà a Catalunya.
Suposo que bé, aquí tenen menys problemes
d'espai i tenen menys gent, sobretot.
A Croàcia són poca gent.
Bueno,
bastant semblant als nostres cementiris, no?
En realitat.
Val, sembla que
no només hi ha un restaurant obert, sinó
que hi ha un restaurant obert.
N'hi ha més d'un. O sigui que
a sobre et puc escollir. Ostres, tu,
aquesta sí que no m'ho esperava. Supermercat
també hi ha, bueno, això ja m'ho esperava.
Perfecte, tu,
perfecte. Són les onze, realment
aprofito per dinar, saps?
Bé, doncs ja ho tenim aquí, tenim un
xevapi, que és el que vaig demanar l'altre dia
que és típic croata,
però avui sense pa de pita, avui el plat
amb aquesta salsa
i una mica de verdures així
a la graella.
Bueno, vaig a dinar.
Ah, també veieu que,
que tinc aquí una cervesa
i és que ahir
vaig fer dos mil quilòmetres.
El que passa és que ahir no vaig
celebrar perquè va ser un dia horrible i no tenia
ganes de celebrar res. Avui sí,
avui sí, doncs celebrem. Crec que la primera
vegada que vaig fer una cervesa als mil quilòmetres,
doncs vinga, el dos mil, una altra cervesa.
Vaig a dinar.
Una i quart. Hauria
de tornar a caminar,
però s'ha posat
a plorar com una mala cosa, ara, eh?
Abans era plogim, així, que bueno,
va, però es podia caminar.
Ara...
Ara és
pluja, pluja, pluja, eh?
M'espero, m'espero.
No fluixa, eh? No fluixa.
He sortit ja al restaurant perquè dic, ostres,
he de... he de començar
a caminar ja. Són les dues
quaranta, per tant fa més de tres
hores que estic per aquí.
Començaré a caminar. Començaré a caminar
perquè el radar marca que just a sota
d'aquí, just al sud d'aquí,
ja no plou.
Em dic, mai et pots refiar, però bé, segurament
la intensitat serà menor. I bueno, al final
és que he de seguir, he de seguir.
Porto dies
veient aquestes illes que hi ha aquí davant
i mirant-les. I sempre em dona
la sensació que on estic jo
plou i allà no.
Quina injustícia.
Caminant per aquesta carretera
estreta i bastant èpica,
bastant èpica, mira, avui al contrari
que els dies anteriors
que anava, o sigui, ahir, que anava
tipus a un quilòmetre o cinc-cents metres
lluny del mar, avui anem enganxats
i enganxats. Avui el paisatge és bastant
bastant guapo perquè cau la muntanya
directament al mar. Doncs m'he dut
un esglai perquè anava per aquí
i de cop i volta
em pita.
I jo...
I bueno, era un bus, un minibus que...
que em diu, ei, vols pujar?
I jo, no, no. Gràcies,
camino. Per cert,
anava escoltant música, música croata
amb un auricular,
no us penseu que vaig completament aïllat.
He actualitzat la playlist.
Hi ha una playlist de
La volta amb una peu, Spotify,
on poso cançons
dels països on estic que m'agraden,
cançons que sonen al vídeo
i cançons que m'agraden a mi,
que escolto en general, mentre que miro que no tenen res a veure.
La tindreu, l'enllaç
a la descripció del vídeo i també si busqueu
Spotify Enric Luzant, crec que en principi
us hauria de sortir.
Les 4 i 6.
Bueno, s'ha quedat una tarda
que tampoc diria bona, però millor.
Sense massa pluja
i tranquil·la, sense vent, també.
Val, porto només 23 km i pico.
Avui, clar, com he parat tanta estona ja,
doncs,
intento arribar als 30, que és com el mínim
que m'estic posant cada dia, no?
Això vol dir que hem de caminar
fins passades les 5 i mitja,
que no m'agrada caminar fins tan tard,
però sí, convé avançar,
convé avançar una mica, ja que podem.
Bona tarda, gairebé a les 5.
No he arribat als 30,
estic als 28,
però potser em quedo aquí.
Mireu, estic a una casa abandonada.
Us en recordeu de fa dos dies
que em vaig trobar a un japonès i un ucranià?
Doncs em van aviar a la ubicació
d'un lloc on havien dormit,
que diu que havien dormit molt bé.
I jo els vaig dir,
ostres, és aquí, és una casa abandonada,
i dic, ostres, hi ha rates,
hi ha coses?
I diu, no, no, no, no, no.
Superbé.
Què hi ha que estic veient?
Palla, palla.
I van dormir aquí sobre la palla, eh?
Home, dormir directament sobre aquí
em fa cosa.
Però bé, ficant
la iant, l'esterilla sobre, sí.
Sí, ells van dormir bé.
Està realment...
Està realment abandonada.
Però
sembla que l'estructura està en bon estat.
Està en bon estat.
Bueno, sí, això no ha sigut
una caiguda fortuïta, entenc.
Més palla hi ha aquí.
Bueno, entenc que això s'utilitza.
Utilitza algú per guardar...
Com podeu veure, encara plou.
Llavors, clar, és molt convenient
estar aquí per evitar la pluja
i per evitar,
haver de plantar
mentre plou,
que això és un rotllo que t'hi cagues.
A veure, Enric, estàs convençut
que això és segur?
Que això no es caurà i tal?
Sembla que ha estat fent caldo, eh?
Diréu alguns.
Bé, jo tot el que he pres
ho he pres a The Metre,
empresa d'Andarrocs,
que és on treballava abans.
He vist molts edificis,
edificis en ruïnes,
edificis que estan a punt de caure,
edificis que tenen una bona estructura.
I, home, realment, aquest és bo, eh?
Dit això,
la gent de The Metre són megaprofessionals
i en saben moltíssim més que jo,
els meus companys.
Llavors, si heu de fer algun Andarroc,
moviment de terres o descontaminació,
doncs contacteu amb ells, que són la millor empresa
de Catalunya d'Andarrocs.
El que sí que us diré és que
dormiré, jo crec que aquí, eh?
Sobre el formigó aquest.
Sembla més sòlid.
Per aquestes fustes mai se sap, eh?
Sí que hi ha sota i...
si pot col·lapsar.
Resum.
28 quilòmetres,
329 metres de desnivell positiu,
dos cafès,
no he parlat amb ningú
i de calés serien
23,50 del restaurant
i 6 euros del supermercat.
No ha sigut un bon dia.
No podríem dir que ha sigut un bon dia.
Però bé, no ha sigut tan lamentable com ahir,
que va ser horrible.
No estem avançant molt ràpid,
però estem sobrevisquent,
que amb aquest temps és complicat.
La veritat és que Croàcia,
m'imaginava una altra cosa,
m'imaginava millor,
però bé, encara queda, eh?
Encara queda la Croàcia.
Esperem que millori.
Demà, la previsió diu que no plou.
Creuem els dits.
I...
encara queda dos dies, crec.
Dos dies sencers, com a mínim,
per arribar a Zadar.
A veure si ja millora una mica.
Bé, a les 5 de la tarda,
encara molta tarda per davant,
us sóc dir bona nit.
Dic, senyors, bona nit, no realment.
Tinc tot el dia per davant.
Però no la nit per vosaltres,
perquè normalment mireu el vídeo per la nit.
O no, no ho sé.
Els que mireu el vídeo cada dia jo rutinàriament,
si voleu, em podeu posar als comentaris
a quina hora del dia mireu el vídeo,
que això sempre em fa gràcia.
Bona nit.